in this video i show you how to
create an online survey with date
up we will discuss the following questions
how do i create an
online questionnaire what types of questions
are there how do i create a filter
how do i create a new page and
a subheading how  i will send out
my survey and how do i get
the results this is the last video
on the topic of questionnaires if you
like you can read the content in our
book questionnaires made easy
you can find the link in the video
description and we will start with that
right away if  only on datatec who is hip
just click on online survey on
this page you can now easily
start creating a survey if
you do not have a data sap license yet,
a survey is simply saved in a browser
as soon as you have a license,
the survey is stored on our servers
saved and you can send them via link
but more later
we will start with de  r creating
the survey up here you can
give your survey a title and add a
description e.g.
student satisfaction with the online emptiness
as a description this is the
description of the survey if you
want to add a new question
just click on plus question now you need
just select the question type that you
just want we'll go through the
different question types briefly so that
the roughly promises when to use which question
type for a precise explanation of
the different question types you
're welcome to watch a detailed video for this
the first two questions are open
questions in  text form the only
difference is that the text field is
small and larger with these
two questions you can ask a hopeful
question, for example for feedback
on a certain product but be careful
if you want to quantitatively evaluate your question later
you should
use these questions sparingly because  the
quanti  static evaluation of open-ended
questions is quite time-consuming the next
open-ended question only allows numerical
answers with this question you can,
for example, ask about
a person's salary, income or weight
if you are asking about a metric
variable you should use
this question type if possible  hopefully
the age will also be asked in categories or
groups and the respondents
only have to tick which age group
they are in. in this case
you will lose valuable
information. now the classic
single choice and multiple
choice questions come with and without an open
text field because it's just a choice
Do you give the respondents answer
options and they may only select one answer
, for example what is your
current marital status single
married witt getting divorced
separated it is important that the respondents
can only look at one answer if you
simply select a selection with an optional text field
, the per
You can also give a free answer. For example, your
favorite online video streaming
service Netflix Amazon Prime Disney Plus
Apple TV and others. Where the person
can enter another streaming provider, multiple selection is very similar.
In this case, the respondent can
select multiple answers
, for example  when do
you use the product xy
morning noon evening night if
someone uses the product e.g. in the morning
and now it is possible to
tick both is very important but make
sure before you
select the multiple choice question multiple choices are also selected for the
question if multiple answers are really possible
,
although only one  answer makes sense
then the evaluation of this data is
then associated with more effort
and then of course there is also the
multiple selection with in a text field
then the question types come
in tables in relation to the matrix
here you can form several rows that
you  then everyone can be rated with the same scales
you use this type of question
, for example, if you
want to create a legal one you can find out more about this
in the video on the lakers
precisely because it is easy to
select a value can be clicked on in each row
the same thing is now also available  still with
multiple selection here several answer options can then be clicked in a
row
but at this point
again the note this type of question
is very very rare in
most cases you simply use
selection in table form it is intentional
that only one answer per row
is not possible  absolutely simple selection in
table form otherwise you will make
life difficult for yourself later with the evaluation
and the last type the linear
scale which is also semantically called the
differential here you can
enter a text on the left and right and
have it evaluated on a number scale,
shall we say  want a
simple selection then we click
just click on it now you can formulate the question
and give an optional
instruction which gender you are
male female diverse furthermore
it can also indicate whether this
field is a mandatory field or not questions that have to
be listed as mandatory can not be
filled out the survey
otherwise  be sent if
you click next to the question you can see what
it looks like in the survey if you click
the question again you
can edit it you can delete the request by
clicking on the cross up
here now we can add another
question, for example  more
preselection you use the product
xy
morning noon evening
if you click on the dots above
you can change the order of the questions
now let's add another
question and for this we set a
filter we want this question to be displayed only
if  the person interviewed is
female and this person receives the product xy
in the morning before  so we click on
filter now we will use the question as a filter,
which gender are you from
and as the value we take female if
we now click on done this
question will only be displayed if the
respondent has previously ticked female
but we want another one
condition so we click on plus and
select the question use the
product xy here we would then have the
value in the morning and done if we now
also go to the preview we see the
preview of the survey the question is only
displayed if female and product xy
in the morning is selected  is currently we
do not see the filtered question we click
but also female and in the morning the
question is displayed and the preview outside
you can look at it again a
finished survey looks like
now there is a heading section
and page break heading section
is simply a sub-heading with
the ecb can mark a new area and a
questionnaire  and
you can give a short explanation this
is a cheerful headline
currently all questions
are displayed on one page do you want the
survey to be divided into several
pages you can do that with the time
change now a
new page will be created at this point let's take a look  once
we see that we only have the
headline and the first question
click on continue we come to the
next question so we now know how to
create a survey once
the questionnaire has been created you can fill out the
questions here as a test on this page
to send the questionnaire out
you must have a data tab
license the survey tool is included in a
normal stair license so
you can use the statistics calculator and the
survey tool together i
would like to talk to my windows
server and now a
link that you can easily share with the people
who should participate
just open the link
yourself as a test then you will see
that the survey will open so
you can simply send the link by email
or
share it on social media and finally on the last
page you will see the response and you can
either download the results as an
excel  or open the direct data tab
but before you start with the
survey,
make sure that
all functions work
the way you thought they
would  hat just write me in the
comments of this video i hope
you liked the video and see
you next time